faire ses courses de noël sur internet
une pratique désormais à disposition de
bien des parents qui font leur marché
aux jouets directement sur la toile
elisabeth est gelée vers dar connor la
lettre au père noël a fait ses preuves
pour leurs commandes
marine et valentin s'ils prennent
toujours de la même façon je voudrais la
scène des plis mobile national et ben
sadoun et un vélo mais leurs parents
changent de méthode
depuis deux ans pour limiter le stress
et la corvée des courses ils choisissent
sur catalogue et achètent sur le nhs à 6
euros et ensuite la cuisine des tout
petits les jouets sont 10% plus cher
qu'en grande surface et la livraison à
domicile en 48 heures coûte 10 euros par
commande mais c'est tout confort je
commande j'irai une moitié sur sur le
net l'autre en grande surface
mais pour moi c'est avant tout un moyen
pratique et rapide
les joueurs arrivent très rapidement et
lorsque l'on n'est pas satisfait on a
quand même la chance de les renvoyer
ici les jouets descendent du ciel
réellement par milliers deux cent
cinquante mille articles dans cet
entrepôt
nous sommes près de lille chez le numéro
un de la vente de jouets par
correspondance pour honorer les 6000
commandes journalières
le père noël a besoin de beaucoup dead
en ce moment l'effectif est multiplié
par 7 2 millions de jouets vont être
livrées dans toute la france en décembre
sont aujourd'hui sur croissance de 10% à
l'année avec une très forte part de
marché sur le net
nous avons aujourd'hui 20% de commandes
qui arrivent par le net pense que par
l'aspect facilité mon sens de nos
clients mais globalement c'est une
percée encore timide seulement 85 % des
jouets sont achetés par correspondance
contre 44% en hyper et supermarchés
du ski